hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast cell imaging and luminescence
based cytotoxicity analysis I am Judy
O'Rourke elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Lavery and
brought to you by perkin-elmer a leading
provider of multimode detection plate
readers and life science lab solutions
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive in the included ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green to innate button at the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or sharing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or your problem to
the green Q&A button lower left I would
now like to introduce today's speakers
dr. frail kahan oh and dr. Philip ribbon
for alpha Hanold of the biology and
achieved her PhD in 2011 at the
University of Cologne Germany she joined
perkinelmer in May 2011 as part of the
application support team based in
Hamburg Germany the team provides
support for the multi-mode detection
plate readers to customers sales and
service women this team proud come
mainly focuses on providing assistance
on imaging and label free applications
including training and application
development dr. Philip Griffin is the
chief scientific officer at the
fraunhofer ime which recently integrated
with the european screening porte EST
and which is based in hamburg germany
and works mainly with academic research
institutes in the area of drug discovery
the ESP uses a range of high-throughput
screening HTS systems and sa methods and
provide support for biomarker studies
within clinical and preclinical research
projects
fed up of the ESP dr. Gribben has worked
in close collaboration with leading life
science industry partners such as
perkinelmer to help validate novel
technologies which are can directly
apply to projects I will now turn it
over to dr. Falco handle for her
presentation thank you very much Judy
for the introduction yes i would like to
start first with some experiments that
we have done here in our lab to show
what the incite multimode reader is
capable to do in terms of multi
parametric analysis of cytotoxicity and
i just want to quickly tell you what the
insight multimode reader is to just to
give you a quick overview so the
multimode reader the inside has
different measurement modes so it is
included conventional a bird
technologies like absorbance
measurements fluorescence intensity
luminescence alpha and trf we have on
board the label-free technology which is
a corning technology and now which is
pretty new we have the well imaging
measurement mode available on that
instrument the inside imaging module
acquires one image / well with a 4x
objective and you can see on the left
and the image a raw image of HeLa cells
this image was generated on the inside
system and gives you a feeling for and
how the images look like and you can
also see in there in the zoomed in part
how well you can see you the cells with
it with the inside the different imaging
modes that are provided by this
instrument are bright field imaging
digital phase imaging also called TPI
and fluorescence imaging with the inside
because we acquire only one image / well
we have really short reading times per
plate with less than six minutes minutes
for a 384-well plate so the inside is
the very fast and sufficient method to
capture all the cells in a well and
actually to provide orthogonal
approaches but I will come in to that
and more detail later on what we can do
with the inside is so this instrument
allows for quickly determining the cell
number and the confluency in a well also
for cell lines with diverse growth
morphologies we can detect incorrect
self-feeding by looking at the cells or
incorrect liquid handling we can also
detect bacterial contamination and
aggregating compounds with that
instrument so it is in general a very
very good tool for controlling cell
based assays with brightfeet digital
phase and fluorescence imaging
measurement methods what I would like to
show you today is how we can also detect
cytotoxic compounds and well why did we
choose cytotoxicity so cytotoxicity can
be caused by different types of agents
so meaning for example by drugs
pathogens immune cells and external
stress vectors and cytotoxicity is still
a major cause for drug withdrawal during
drug development the cell desk that the
cells undergo through the cytotoxic
effects includes a complex signaling
programs that lead to a variety of
different phenotypes so for example you
get nuclear fragmentation selves
shrinkage membrane blebbing or loss of
membrane integrity leakage of cell
content and swollen nuclei so with these
phenotypes cytotoxicity is an idiot
application to be analyzed using cell
emitting and you can use that easily in
addition to conventional cytotoxicity as
it and what we have done here in our lab
is so we have used an orthogonal
cytotoxicity approach so we have
collected different datasets from
different readouts so we have looked for
the cell morphology with stainless
bright field imaging we have looked at
in more detail on the nuclei and have
determined different characteristics of
the nuclei with fluorescent imaging
using a nuclear stain
we have determined cytoplasmic enzyme
activity with the imaging mode with
fluorescence imaging and using an enzyme
dependent cytoplasm stain and we have
also used a conventional cytotoxicity
assay which is the level of
intracellular ATP which we have measured
with the luminescence reach out and the
workflow of the experiments that we have
done are the following so we have seeded
hela cells on the view played 384 so
approximately 1,500 cells per well and
have seeded them and on day one we did a
bright field imaging measurement and
private analysis then we edit DMSO which
is our model compound in this case and
incubated two cells at 37 degrees
overnight on the second day we did also
a bracelet image analysis after the the
treatment after this bright kid imaging
and analysis we have added disdain for
the nucleus and the cytoplasm and use
the fluorescent imaging capabilities of
the instrument and the analysis to look
for the nucleus characteristics and the
cytoplasm and at the end we remove part
of the supernatant which was important
for due to the limited volume that we
had available in the in the well and
edit the ATP kit solution which is a kid
that detects the ATP the intracellular a
deeper level and for this we measured
the cells in luminescent yes and the
results so what you see here is on the
left you see a divided well so the upper
left corner is the weld on day one where
you can see that it you have a rather
low confluency of the cells which is
different on
day 2 which is the upper right corner
marked with a 2 here you see the
untreated cells so which means you can
see how the cells just divide it
overnight and their fluency is
increasing and on the right you see a
treated well so on day one and the cells
look all healthy and on the second day
you see that the cells are there are
shrinking based on the on the DMS all
treatment what we have now done with the
inside is we have used the bright fesh
confluency analysis which is a preset
analysis tool on the inside and what it
does is it automatically discriminates
between empty areas and the area that is
covered by self and what you can see on
the in the untreated well on the left on
day two after treatment you get a
confluency as about of about sixty-five
percent but if the cells are treated so
meaning your cells are shrinking the
confluent see decreases and you get a
constituency of only twenty-nine percent
and if you now evaluate that and and
plotted against the DMS or concentration
you see on the left that the confluency
decreases with increasing gamers or
concentration remember where that we
have done the bright hit imaging on day
one and day too so if you if you
subtract the confluency determined on
day one from each well then you get also
information about side aesthetic and
cytotoxic effect so meaning you can see
the orange line is actually the the line
that distinguish between cells that have
been just stopped growing and cells that
are really lies and that are dying so
with this approach doing imaging on one
day and on the second days or doing this
kinetic approach you can distinguish
between these two effects another
parameter that is provided
by the instrument is the foreground
roughness so this is the parameter it
can also be used to determine and
toxicity actually so there you get it's
a texture parameter that uses the
texture of the cell area and this
texture introduced you to enhanced
roundness of the dining set so this is
the parameter that can also be used and
to determine cytotoxicity and the other
approach so you see here we have now
added stained and this tooth pain so one
was the boost the rich stain which
stains the nuclei it's more less strange
all cell so it is independent on if the
cells are dead or not and we've also
added calcein a.m. which is an enzyme
dependent cytoplasm stain and this same
stains only living cells and what you
can see in the images is the untreated
cells they show homogeneous nuclear
staining and humid gina's cytoplasm
standing in green and shown in blue here
on the right panel you see the overlay
but if you look at the DMSO treat
yourself you see that there are tiny and
bright small nuclei it's shown and only
a few cells are positive for caffeine
a.m. and the way we determined and the
cytotoxicity was that we use the preset
collider seitan look analysis and what
this analysis does is so first of all
this analysis automatically looks for
the nucleus than who so it detects where
is a cell where do I find the nucleus
after that it produces or it yeah it
forms a ring structure around the nuclei
to analyze the cytoplasm stain intensity
of this ring so in that case we have
analyzed in more detail the intensity of
the calcium staying around the nucleus
which you can this is shown on the
picture in the middle
and using this analysis for both treated
and untreated itself you get you get
different analysis parameter are off
hospitalist analysis and I will now
switch to the nucleus characteristics
first so what you can see here is if you
look at the game at all concentration
versus a nuclear number of nuclei the
median look this area and the median of
this intensity you see here changes
depending on the DM and our
concentration and in the upper graph you
can see that the nuclei that the number
of nuclei decreases if you increase the
DMSO concentration so and this is
obviously based on cell death and the
nucleus area this is one to one in the
middle is based on the nucleus shrinking
so this area decreases with increasing
VMs or concentration which is just
because the cells are dying and shrink
the median luckless intensity and in
contrast increases with increasing dms
alkane concentration and this is due to
nuclear condensation this is one reason
so you get a smaller nuclei and in
addition the smaller nuclei have a
higher amount per volume higher amount
of staying for volume so meaning they
the intensity of these nuclei appears
brighter another parameter that we get
out of it out of this and Saito nuke
analysis is the intensity of the calcium
so this is the parameter that is
detected in the ring structure around
the nucleus and what you can see here is
that the light green curve that you see
is actually the labeled approach as I
have explained it so far so we detect
first the nuclei stain and then
determine in the ring structure around
it determine the
cytoplasm Spain intensity and what you
can see here we get an easy 50 of zero
point forty two percent the dark green
in contrast is a bit different so there
we have used a stainless approach so
this means we have not used the roots
pain at all but we have used the digital
phase imaging which produces um or which
which forms an image and which which
gives you the shape of the cell more or
less and this digital face image so
detect the whole cell and in that case
we have detect the whole cell first and
determine the intensity inside the cell
and this is a nice approach because you
don't need the who stained and can use
this detection method for cells that are
only stay with calcium for example and
you see the ec 50 values with both
detection methods are the same and just
to to understand what the calcn am is
actually doing so what you see with
increasing him at all concentrations you
get a decrease of coffee and this is
typical because the coffee in am is just
fluorescent if it is converted by
intracellular enzymes and our orthogonal
approach here was the luminescence sa
that we have done using the ATP light
kit this is the kid as i have mentioned
already which determines intracellular
levels of ATP and it's frequently used
to detect zelda what we have done here
is you can see on the left the plate map
of our a decade and what we have done is
so we have compared wealth that contain
the stain of the fluorescent imaging
already and cells without the stain and
add at the adp light kit on top of it
the plate I've we've used is the blacks
you play 384 which might be surprising
for the one
that are used to luminescent essays
because usually luminescence essays are
done in white plate additionally because
we have an imaging played with the clear
button we cover the plate with white
backfield and to decrease luminescence
crosstalk and you can see there on the
plate map you don't have any cross talk
with respects you and the AGP light once
that kid was added after two hours of
the stain addition of food and caffeine
and what we got out of it is our the
graph you can see here so what you see
is the ATP light only without having
disdain still present in the solution is
result in the same ec50 value as plus
stain so and both curves are very very
similar and what you see here is that
the HP light one step kit is not
influenced at all by the presence of
first and calcium stain in the
supernatant and this nicely shows that
you can easily combine fluorescent
imaging with the HP light for example my
feet or this needs to be tested for
different kid a kid or different kids
and different stains but in that case it
is really nice because don't have to
take care of the stain and can yeah can
can look at from different angles to
yourself and to summarize all the ec50
values that we got for our
multiparametric cytotoxicity assays what
you see is the most of the most of the
1850s are pretty similar between two and
three percent but what is very very
prominent here is the values you see in
green so here the green shows the
results for the enzyme dependent
cytoplasm stain the car scene and here
you see that the ec50 value is yeah it
is reduced in contrast to the other ec50
edges
and this is this makes sense because the
calcium is known to be a very early
event in apoptotic cells so the cahsee
isn't sits more sensitive to GMS or
concentrations than the other regions
are and yeah with this approach you see
that you can distinguish between
different levels of cytotoxicity using
fluorescent dyes and just to summarize
so I'm with the insights you can gain
more data and findings faster out of
your sample to confirm your results you
can check as the cell morphologies cell
nucleus and cytoplasm characteristics as
well as intracellular ATP levels you can
do that all and one well so you get the
complete picture of cytotoxicity on
different levels you can watch cell
proliferation and compound effect by
using stainless bright freakin fluency
analysis so this is a really robust and
easy to apply approach it's non-invasive
and this lifestyle SI and it can also
distinguish between cytostatic versus
cytotoxic effects yeah and the power of
image segmentation in the fluorescent
image analysis is that you can
distinguish between nucleus and
cytoplasm and it allows for more
detailed analysis of different effects
of cytotoxicity and with adding a
well-known intracellular ATP
measurements using luminescence you
could get a full the full picture and
you yeah in that case you use the
orthogonal approach which confirms your
well imaging-based results yes so and
this is it from my part and now I would
like to hand over to fill ok thanks a
lot protests and okay so my name is so
Goodman from the from of the irony here
in Hamburg um just got a 12 slides just
to orientate you but I'm who we are and
what we're looking for essentially in
them in terms of screening technologies
and I theta
tease and thank the farmers one of the
largest applied research organizations
in Europe I think about 23,000 people
working me about 5,000 work in the lab
science area and in a small part of it
we're predominately interested in sport
monkey with drug discovery so that
involves asset development primary
screening of up to and 500,000 compounds
in any one campaign and profiling with
those compounds in terms of confirming
the efficacy in the primary and the
secondary essays but also in building of
a sufficient amount of information to
let you understand what the off target
lither it is some of the compounds might
be in order to be able to then remove
compounds from the workflow which and
maybe have cytotoxic effects and which
you don't want to advance into and
further optimization and the judge of
the people are coming from either
industry or whole biotech backgrounds so
in terms of and the acid systems and
again it's this maps on to what we're
looking for from from reader systems and
we have a lot of academic targets and
that means that you're you're often
faced with them some quite difficult and
challenging and mechanisms to
investigate and to find modulator school
particularly is important for in
interactions and so we tend to do a lot
of MHC RF experiments a lot of alpha
screens of experiments along with the
touch classes where you would have
learned the genetic origin substrates
for instance and kinase employees that
set foot in set cetera and we're also
interested in and top phenotypic as well
as target these readouts and what I'm
going to go through today is really an
application of the s side in a
phenotypic acid format where we looking
to characterize compounds coming from a
marine fungi source trying to understand
what their anti-cancer properties might
be so it's not really from the and
the toxicological toxicological
perspective where you're eliminating
compounds that really we're looking for
compounds which have specific patterns
of toxicity against cell lines which are
well characterized and well defined in
which we source from the NCI panel in
the National Cancer Institute in the
u.s. so just and our workflow is very
similar to that was characterized by a
broker and what we wanted to do is we
had them over a thousand compounds and
we were looking to profile with
compounds against up to 35 cell lines
from the NCI panel in a phenotypic I see
where we're looking for compounds which
inhibit the growth of the cell lines and
compounds which would also have
cytotoxic properties so we do self
feeding and then add the compounds or
control compounds of DMSO up to 24 hours
wait for 48 hours and then our classical
workflow before we really had access to
be and the N side and other imaging
techniques and was to divide those
detection using cell title glue or ATP
light or other types of and metabolic
readouts using ATP a surrogate for cell
number and that allows you to calculate
from the dose response data decided
toxic effect on the site aesthetic
effect as well this is a again along the
lines of what we've seen with em with
Freud's MATC light and here we're using
the result I to go from promega I think
one thing that's worth pointing out for
all of these and metabolic cellular
metabolism readers if they can be
extremely sensitive so you can get down
to very low selling them but then
certainly the hundreds were in some
cases the 10 10 200 cells is pretty
accessible using some of these and quite
sensitive detection technologies so if
you if you're looking for and
complementary technologies then you need
to be thinking about things which have
similar levels of individual
cell based assessment so they are quiet
and they are quite good technologies and
I think if um you do have to do a
reasonable amount of work and we had 35
cell lines that we wanted to use it in
our panel and our intention was to clean
a thousand compounds in triplicate an
11-point doses one so there was a quite
a lot of work to do in terms of asset
development so we're doing that the
classic estate development Kieth again
for the distal Pettigrew so if we're
looking here we're doing the DMSO
tolerance and you can see the u.s.
always using this in a statuses and
cytotoxicity standard you can say we
want to keep world below one percent and
we'll check in with linearity of the
detection in terms of the number of
cells and we had a panel of standard
compounds where we knew what the the
expected pharmacology would be and there
was this flap in the cup of urine stores
born and paclitaxel and also we were
running some experiments with why we
wanted to see whether there was some
counter as a effect whereby the
compounds were effectively detection
reagents and we also pick up some hints
of that so some of the compounds and
again it's a such a vision but what
we're seeking to do with these and
phenotypic assays is obviously there's
an underlying target that we're hoping
that the compounds will be modulating in
some beneficial way and the problem we
have is that of we don't know what that
target is in many cases so the NCI of a
quite a nice tool called compare
analysis will buy you're able to em look
at the profile of activities of your
compound and they'll blow that into a
database where it's then compared
against and the profile of activities
against different cell lines of standard
compounds with standard kinase
inhibitors h-dog inhibitors etc it can
use a correlation analysis and the thing
to 38,000 compound profiles available in
there and that will give you your first
indication of what the mechanism of
action maybe if your compound if it
matches or at least call it in some way
with the M the profile seen for the
standard
and you can see here that it can be this
is a result for cisplatin which is one
of the standard and compounds that we
used across all of the screen here and
cisplatin is MBNA cross linking agent
and you can see here when we compared
and cisplatin against 171 compounds
which is found in ER and in the the
standard drug set on the complaint
database that we get very good
correlation and in terms of the rank
cisplatin and cisplatin like compounds
or highly represented in the top series
if we look at the 38,000 compounds in
the entire database and you can see
again that cisplatin and compounds which
are similar mechanisms action and DNA
cross-linking to cisplatin again are
highly ranked so I think this is just a
message that and listing technologies
are very good it's good databases out
there that can help you understand what
the preliminary madness of action and
worthy of your compounds might be so
everything looks rosy in the garden but
um it isn't really the case and I think
we have to look at and where they are
some problems with ATP detection and
it's certainly not a universal readout
and um there's a prawn buzzards body of
evidence at certain cell growth and
toxicity magnums are not adequately
represented in this biz metabolic reader
and essentially the compounds which can
either increase the size of cells or
increase the mitochondrial content
themselves and they could give you and
they could miss inform you with respect
to the potential cytotoxic effects of
your compound and I think another thing
which is missing and there are some new
technologies which are coming on board
the steady flow systems but certainly in
the classic themselves had a go in a
tepee life is the fact that you need to
allow yourself to release the ATP in
order to be able to run your measurement
and this means you've got a one-time
endpoint measurement and I think that
whilst us that's very good and can be
and
sort of helpful in terms of fruitful
actually you're missing a trick so you
can miss a trick sometimes somebody and
the mechanisms of action cytotoxicity
can appear on the timescales of minutes
or hours particularly for instance
membrane disrupting reagents with
detergents etc and whereas the site
itself is effects of other compounds can
happen over many days and it can be of
use when you again triaging your
compound to try and understand what the
kinetic component of the cytotoxicity is
for a particular compounds and then
using that as a filter or not in in
selecting for compounds and also you
know these reagents are relatively
expensive so it gives an additional
detection reagents so there may be an
opportunity to reduce costs so this is
worth where we were coming from as an
organization using these types of
technologies on a on a day-to-day basis
so I think we've had a am an explanation
the way the right field is illumination
works and from Frau Kerr and having the
the N side on board is allowed us to em
to see what to what degree we can
transfer all pre-existing ATP base we'd
have saved in transfer those to a label
and non label let's say rather than
label free but a non label non stained
non additional detection reagent
required weighed out for and cell
viability and so the M key and
parameters the thing I've already
mentioned these and I think what apart
from the and the general confluency
parameters which are sort of telling you
how much of this surface is covered by
self there's also a number of very
interesting parameters which really
indicate what's happening on and on a
very localized area within the cells and
these are based upon the roughness my
based upon local changes in intensity
and we've been really just experiment
and playing around to a certain degree
to trying to understand using the
pharmacology of known compound standards
to guide us to try and understand what
these parameters are telling us about
the health of the cells at
point in time so we've got these various
parameters and I'm going to look at some
of those now and see which which is
useful and which are not quite so useful
and which ones maybe even giving us
early indications and the same way that
the calcined I mentioned earlier on
early indications of cytotoxic effects
within the cell so i think the the basic
and prom that you need to be able to
determine in these imaging based methods
is and confluency so here you can see
for and there's a two cell lines for the
mcf-7 and the 70 60 that we can measure
changes in conference lee confluency and
quite successfully over a different time
periods and without seemingly adversely
affecting the cells and the measurement
time procreated is relatively lower at
less than four minutes at this basic
read out with any without any
fluorescence channels and we can use
that as an essentially a quality control
measure within the screen duty to ensure
that the number of cells that we have is
consistent across a number and wells
within a plate and that our dispensing
systems are working adequately and when
we measure confluency in the presence of
DMSO and at 0 and 5 to send and also
partner taxa you can see there that you
beginning then to see changes so where
you at the top one here we just have no
phone 5s ND and I saw the confluency
increases are expected at a higher
percentage of DMSO over time up to 72
hours you seeing that the cell growth is
being redundant here so it is a cell
growth inhibition and you can see for
patent attacks ls5 micromolar that
you're seeing a cytotoxic effect with
time so these are basic parameters and
if we're now moving away from the
coverage of the cells actually looking
at the the local roughness parameters
and the local texture based parameters
associated with the cells here is it
another couple of examples here now you
can see here I am
hi DMSO concentration that you're
getting a an increase in in the
roughness and you can see again similar
with sorry this is high after-tax cell
concentration is causing an increase in
bookmans without your five to send DMSO
you're seeing a no change there and at
your load a little concentration you're
seeing a reduction in roughness and this
is indicative of the cells healthy cells
spreading along the bottom of the plate
and in the same sort of parameters are
seen with mcf-7 so you're getting an
increase in this fraction of high high
contrast cells you see no changes with
five percent DMSO and you're seeing a
reduction in this fraction with an
upload ems or concentration so the
roughness based parameters in the
contrast based parameters are giving you
additional information independent of
the conference's based parameters and it
seems to be the changes the relative
changes are larger than we see with the
competency based parameters which gives
you some help like some indication that
you might have an orthogonal
imaging-based without describing what's
happening with itself and here's another
again another parameter in this case is
the foreground roughness you see here an
increase in packet excel it's not
changing in the presence of nor point
five percent a metal so we can we can
plan our way through all of these
different and readers and in this case
we've got em all the different readers
here and we're looking at increasing
concentrations of courtesy and you can
see here with this particular product at
which I can't read on my screen is the
my eyes are getting more yeah so it's so
sorry so this is their confluency here
this is the high contrast and region
roughness this is the roughness range
factor this is the foreground roughness
and this is the low contrast roughness
range in the mean so you can see that
there's significant changes in these
imaging with texture based parameters
associated with increasing
concentrations of practicing and in some
cases switch in the roughness range
factor you can see that the relatively
healthy cells which exports very low
concentrations of caucusing this listing
a reduction in these and these
parameters way as the cells which are
exposed to high concentration of
colchicine you see an increase in these
parameters so it's quite a nice and icy
winger which which is opening up in in
those cases which is in comparison to
the exit the confluency measurement
we're using either an increase relative
to the end to the baseline and again you
can see here we've taken and six
standard compounds and through those
compounds are non cytotoxic which em
cabo per mile and cooling and in phila
coughing and we've got colchicine
paclitaxel trigger study knee and
gentian violet and you can see quite
nicely for thee and for the paclitaxel
and for the the trick is Stephanie that
we're seeing quite nice dose response
them this dose response is forming but
not fantastic I would say with with the
confluency and for then if you compare
the same sets of compound using the
foreground roughness mean you can see
quite nicely develop those responses and
particularly for in the Padma textile
here you see the very large windows
coming up becoming apparent and also for
the the trigger Stephanie nice windows
being in funky it and we did see some
and some problems with the enemy
champion violet and I think that in a
sense
because of some optical interference
between this which is it's a colored
compound not something that we're
looking at into more detail and whether
we can remove the effects of polar
compounds and their influence on these
and on these parameters we can see the
same thing with the roughness range
factor here that the dosa sponsors are
less pronounced and this this in our and
Han seems to be less of a useful derived
parameter but you can still see
substantial dose responses and then we
can compare finally with em the the cell
tighter glow from from for Miguel you
can see here you get you get nice doors
responses but again they're em they're
not too dissimilar to what we observed
with the M the range factors the
roughness status so in terms of that if
we can summarize the data for ATP growth
versus image based analysis these are
all the IC 50 values in expressed in in
micro molar you can see here for the off
standard compounds at 48 hours which was
the last set of data that we're getting
reasonable values for the with the
luminescence read up and but then again
if you compare that to the confluency
you can see again a reasonable
correlation here for colchicine and also
for the the roughness the program versus
parameters and the roughness range
parameters so we seem to have very nice
and correlation in some cases or some
compounds between the luminescence the
confluency and these worthless based
parameters and the are some cases where
and no fit was possible and particularly
for the confluency and some compounds
back to the satiny for instance but
where you weren't able to get a fit with
confluency you're actually able to get a
am quite a reasonable fit using some of
the and the roughness parameter so you
see a good car agency in the point 0 37
and the values that you're getting for
roughness and in the roughness range as
well and these and correlations are also
borne out in a second cell line 2 786
so we're by no means explored all the
possibilities when it comes to
understanding what the different effects
of these compounds are on these
roughness based parameters as measured
using the bright field illumination we
recently see a strong indication that is
a good correlation between what you see
with luminescence and what we see with
an optical based measures of confluency
then also what we can see with these and
roughness based parameters the
foreground roughness and nervousness
range so in terms of the MV overall
performance and we think that certainly
in our hand so far bright field imaging
seems to produce results for confluency
which are consistent with what we seen
with ATP determination and these more
falafel falafel or roughness and based
and features seem to give it at least
useful secondary orthogonal readers and
we're able to read the place relatively
rapidly less than four minutes per plate
and we don't have it in our shop is we
don't have access to an environmental
control of co 2 etc within the confines
of the reader so we're essentially
taking the plate out in reading it
straight away I think these rapid read
times and comparatively and Loan America
latitude of the M of the objectives
allow us to quickly read the plates and
then put them back into their
environment be controlled incubators and
then we're not preserving them
excessively and we've actually taken
around tell 10 cell lines to date and
we've been able to measure these optical
based texture parameters for those those
cell lines reasonably successfully did
require a certain amount of tuning when
it comes to defining the parameters
within the algorithm for identifying the
cells in defining the properties of
cells but we haven't had a cell line so
far that we weren't able to them
usefully extract these parameters
from so where we go next with the with
the inside and we want to extend the
image analysis process to cover
additional cancer cell lines you want to
see whether we can replicate some of the
date where I showed earlier on when it
comes to the compare nalysis and see
whether we can use these optical based
parameters as also as insight into the
potentially what the targets maybe we'll
be screening multiple cell lines in
parallel so that's something that we're
looking to do and getting a cell lines
in place to do that and we want to look
at some of the more problematic
compounds which have been shown in
recent papers to cause an enlargement of
the cell and increase in the proportion
of mitochondria in each cell and see
whether we can get a more reasonable
cytotoxic read out for those compounds
and in the medium term or our goal is
really to see whether we can replace m83
determination with imaging based assays
and you want to be able to measure
effects on growth and effects on
cytotoxicity and that in a sense
requires that you were able to
differentiate between a live seller and
dead cell we're not quite there yet we
can I think we will get to that point
question and that's something that we're
working very closely with the team in
internal attune to achieve so just to
give you an overall impression we've had
the M is the system in our lab for over
six months now and we see the advantages
in terms of having access to an
orthogonal technology and that's always
critical when it comes to M validating
the heads which are coming out of change
because so many compounds can cause out
a faction and causing problems and what
I haven't really talked about today is
the potential to normalize the data and
that would require I think if you had a
screening many many cell plates today
require integration whereby you and you
placed your insight into
an automated workflow where you could
use that vent and ensure that the the
number of cells that you see that well
and make your quality control standards
and I think that's an important
additional quality control feature of
these imaging based systems and they
could be used like that in routine
screening as a as a pre-screen are the
number of cells in their correct and and
to the standard that we expect I think
that there's a lot of potential
associated with using kinetic acids and
interrogating the cytotoxic effects of
compounds it very short and very long
time skills and the ability to do that
without having to live the cell the
thing is very good and that could give
you the potential to rank compounds
according to their kinetic response we
may be looking for compounds which have
a rapid onset effect or you could
consider that many of those compounds
may in fact be membrane disrupting
compounds or detergent like compounds
and the ones that you want to take out
of your and out of your your your
workflow and remove them from the end
from your hit list and we haven't fully
got to the point where we can lower the
cost for detection reagents I think
that's an aspiration in the medium term
once we're completely secure in our
understanding of how the system works
when it comes to the what these
parameters are telling us and but it
could be that new feature that we can do
label-free on no label imaging of
themselves and that could be the one and
only read out i thing is it as a general
from a general perspective the
instrument is pretty straightforward to
use and we are also users of the
invasion and the insight here and it
works and along similar principles and
it's quite possible and with the support
of the team here to be able to adjust
your image analysis parameters and tune
your system to cater for the needs of
additional cell lines as required so I
think that's everything from my
presentation and I can hand back to you
Judy for your m
mixed moderation thank you thank you for
the informative presentation during a
question-and-answer session that follows
to poll questions will appear on the
screen you may select an answer or close
the poll question by clicking on the
text in the right corner before it gets
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button to the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can our
first question is if I obtain so many
different parameters and readouts for my
experiments how do I know which of these
is the right one yeah I mean I think in
in that sort of case you need to be
guided by the pharmacology and the
performance of standard compounds so if
your if your standard compound is the
particular parameter that the foreground
refers mean for instance if that is
giving you pharmacology which is
consistent with what you're expecting
from that compound and similar to what's
report and literature and I think that
that's the one that you should be
investing your time and effort into as
you and your final reader so it is thing
I than any screening it all comes back
you got out if you've got a good
standard compounds to help guide your
your asset development and guide your
quality control to a screen then that's
the end that's always the best thing
that sometimes people don't have that
but on the whole that's that's what
people ambition is or the start of the
screening campaign your next question is
a two-parter how does the image analysis
work and do I need any second there do I
need any special training for the
analysis no you don't need any special
training so the insight is equipped with
Collider which is the analysis software
and there you have different methods
that I have shown also in my
presentation and you just choose one you
have a few parameters that you can
adjust based on your application and
cell type and then you just go so there
is no arm no training needed so it's
really straightforward
what colors can the insight youth for
fluorescent imaging the ensign is
equipped with up to four LEDs and we
have LEDs for from the excitation side
we have LEDs for UV blue green and red
and on the emission style we have a
multiband filter which allows for a
simultaneous emission detection and this
is actually the reason why it is so fast
because we done the emission side we
don't have to switch any filters it was
mentioned that the insight takes less
than six minutes per plate is this
measurement time dependent on the number
of excitation sources yes it is
dependent it's always dependent on the
settings because you might use dyes
there's need longer excitation times
because they are rather than but here i
would like to mention so if you have
more than one channel added to your
protocol it's not doesn't mean that the
measurement time doubles it's
approximately twenty percent that the
measurement time increases and this is
base because you have different
movements for example the movement of
the plate and also there are the time
the autofocus needs that are just done
once per plate and then you have two
additional time for the second channel
but it's not doubling is there evidence
that texture based analyses are more
sensitive to really cytotoxic effects
than confluence or metabolic readouts I
think there's some preliminary evidence
that M for some compounds it seems to be
more sensitive I think we have to do a
more comprehensive assessment as that
and and so that's a sort of that's a
work in progress as it were but and
certainly there they're showing promise
so far as being able to indicating early
stage intracellular events and before
confluency or before metabolic
did you use coated view plates no no we
didn't for the HeLa cells we didn't did
you use one no we don't even don't use
click away but it's not a yeah you can
use them as well so once ATP light
reagent added without washing without
the washing step before yes yes and
that's what it's interesting because you
really just we just removed a bit of the
soup in it which was really just because
otherwise we did not have enough volume
in the well but then we added the ATP
light without any washing it was just
added like that yeah and I think with
the M the cell tied a glow reagent again
we use exactly same place that we had
been them imaging with the N site and we
just run the regular cell tied to glow
and for the color adding I think it's an
equal volume of the cell technical
region and then reading the
sophisticated imaging technology seems
to be geared toward adherence cell line
and would replace classical assays
example MTT or xpg how is applicable
atif or cell mediated cytotoxicity
assays especially in suspension cultures
or effector and target cells that are
often in clusters to be analyzed I think
that's a really tough one and in our
experience and we tend we tend to stick
to adherence cell lines in many of these
cases and we do see with em no not here
in suspension cell lines that eventually
the cells do fall to the bottom the
plate which is that they don't adhere
they tend to cluster and crumpets as
well and a little in a little circle at
the bottom so when I think at the moment
it made me you may need other other
technologies I think if you're working
with em suspension cell lines and I
think there is a range of that
it's a M that is an issue I agree for
you or you would probably use stains for
the suspension cells because I mean it's
obvious that the bright field is not
very effective because suspension cells
are around anyway and but you could use
like toxicity stains and use that for
suspension cells yeah i mean i have to
say we've used it and we haven't
presented the data here but we've used
it in some IPS lined some primary
primary and rat and mir ein lines that
we've we've used here and it's been very
successful in indoors as well so it's
not just these were engineered heck
healer mcf-7 pipelines that if you saw
four we've used it across the whole
ranges and IPS human IPS dried lines and
them it's been quite nice especially in
combination with the fluorescence i
think that will that will be in a future
presentation when we when we talk to
that data but that's that's quite nice
which liquid acoustic instrument is used
and for for adding the compounds in our
case we use it i am using echo and i
think for a variety of reasons because
you want to keep the m4 the cytotoxicity
want to keep the compounds in suspension
in DMSO in solution and DMSO for as long
as possible and there before adding to
the m to the plate of ourselves i think
all the other and liquid handling is it
standard janeth techniques or we seed
using movie drops etc so there it is
there's nothing there's nothing special
about this liquid hunting it's the types
of instrumentation that you find within
it in a regular good discovery lab or
you know a love which is got a teak on
over there is a similar types of robotic
systems in place can one differentiate
between different cells in a
heterogeneous culture system yes yes no
so with the current group
we have seen some yeah some exciting
data for and the bright field confluence
the analysis actually you because you
have there in the settings you can
adjust the contrast threshold and with
that you can to some extent and
distinguish between two different
morphologies ourselves additionally we
can provide custom scripts for the
inside so this would also be a
possibility to adjust the method that we
provide yeah on the instrument to make
that possible compounds back into cell
cycle arrest might need first to
swallowing themselves before they
actually undergo apoptosis would def
you're right guess to compare ATT life
versus any phenotype genotype it sa I
think in those types of compounds it
would be extremely interesting to get a
kinetic assessment of what's going on so
looking at one hour five hours ten hours
and I think that that can give you a lot
of information that what's happening
every compound potentially has a
different effect well and I think that
that's where i am the the imaging based
methods have a have a real advantage and
over simple endpoint methods is the
media color interfere with detection
analysis so I thingy you can't use mph
dies with the cell type of glory with
the ATP life but I don't think it
interferes with the imaging itself but
it doesn't affair with with some of the
luminescence and reagents so that's
something to be to be careful of but not
with the imaging itself it's no not
really in our experience I think we may
have run out of time for answering
questions give me just a second here and
just confirm this
t I I think we I think we have run out
of time for questions so I would like to
thank our sponsor perkinelmer for making
today's educational webcast possible
there were a number of questions we did
not get to today's so questions you do
not have time to answer will be answered
via email today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
November 26 2015 you'll receive an email
from lab roots for learning you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to afford that
announce me to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time bye